ACTION TONIGHT.
THAT'S HARD ENOUGH, TO MAKE UP
STANLEY CAME UP WITH IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE HELD IN, AND D.
EHLERS PUTS IT BACK..
JUST BEFORE THAT GOAL, THEY DO
HOMETOWN TEAM.
OH, THE  AS A HAWKS GO TO .
THEY HAVE TWO GAME AND IT'S TAY
IN THE LAST 6 GA
>> Haley: THE INCREDIBLE TEAM .
>>
>> Haley: THAT'S REA
CALEB JONES..
CONNOR HELLEBUYCK, BUT
NEVERTHELESS,  IS ABLE TO HOLD
OFF  RIGHT ON THE BACK
POST.
AGAIN, ANOTHER
HERE COMES SETET A GOOD SET .
HE PUT TOWARDS THE MIDDLE.
THAT W W
>> Haley: SORRY, PAT. AND HE MO
BLAKE WHEELE
LEFT IT FOR SCHEIFELE
SCHEIFELE.
HEHE. NOW
IT'SHE'S BEEN ON THE
DOORSTEP ALL NIGHT TONIGHT AND
OVER THAT WAY. SETH JONES, WIDE.
HE'S GOING TO DROP I THE ICE.
RIGHT ACROSS THE OTHER WAY,
IT'S A 50-50
BATTLE.
THEY MAKE E  THE CATCH.
NOW DEFLECTING, GETSALEX
DEBRINCAT IN THIS GAME.
HEHE